when I was younger I used to be really
into Trivial Pursuit and sometimes I
would memorize the backs of the cards so
I could win and that's how I learned
some of my favorite trivia like there's
a name for those three asterisks in the
book when the vibe changes it's called a
dinkus and I also learned that Oklahoma
has a state vegetable and it's a
watermelon I've always really liked
trivia PR precisely because it's
information that carries no
responsibility at all if you forget the
information that's going to be on your
test or your mom's birthday you might
have consequences but you never have a
test on state vegetables it's learning
that's just for
fun I've always been pretty curious I
graduated um in 2022 and my favorite
parts of my Neuroscience classes were
not necessarily the nitty-gritty
physiology I really liked the funnier
stuff like the protein and limb
development named Nam after Sonic the
Hedgehog or this bridged bicyclic
molecule that looks like a Teenage
Mutant Ninja
Turtle not all of my coursework was so
Charming but I tried to convince myself
that everything was at least a little
bit interesting one of the best ways to
make things more interesting is to learn
more than you have to my favorite place
for a long time to quench my curiosity
is Wikipedia the free online
encyclopedia that anyone can edit I've
been a longtime fan um I journaled about
my Wikipedia reading habits when I was
in fifth grade um and when classes went
online in 2020 I find I found myself
scrolling through all these Wikipedia
articles and contributing anyone can
edit the site some of the things I read
had to do with my coursework like I
learned that the p in PH doesn't stand
for anything okay I also learned about
things that had no relation to my
classes fictional worms nonwater
floods before I could think too long
about what it would have been like to
live in London when beer was flowing
through the streets I was reading about
go blue and B U fake towns they don't
exist but they were put on the official
Michigan map in the Ohio section at the
bottom by mischievous map makers in the
70s
I started screenshotting my favorite
pieces of trivia on Wikipedia and I put
them on Instagram and that was in the
early pandemic and I'm still doing it um
I posted things like the Michigan State
Professor who took this model kidney to
Disney World to see if roller coasters
help pass kidney stones they
do good to
know Wikipedia is created by real people
unlike traditional Publishers or other
encyclopedias it doesn't require that
you're an expert in your
field this is a user whose name is Diana
who has written probably everything you
know about World War II and also P
didy there are thousands of people like
this you don't have to be an expert you
just have to be able to synthesize
sources and follow Style Guidelines
those guidelines are strict but not so
strict that a little personality doesn't
shine through
sometimes this article about the pop
mobile I think has quite a bit of
Personality it says John Paul II
requested that the media stop referring
to the car as the pop mobile saying that
the term was
undignified the popmobile and then it
goes on and
on I'm also a fan of the Wikipedia
editor who saw this caption about a bag
Piper and a penguin and decided to
clarify which was the
bagpiper thank you very helpful I'm I'm
a fan of the Wikipedia editor that
submitted this photo for Vienna bread
that has motion blur for some
reason Wikipedia sometimes feels
infinite um in and I'm sure you've heard
warnings that it's not not perfect maybe
your seventh grade teacher said don't
use Wikipedia anyone can edit it and
it's true that there is some
misinformation and disinformation on the
site often it's only up for a few
seconds or minutes but sometimes hoaxes
last longer for example there was an
article for 10 years about an Aboriginal
God Called garito wz It didn't site any
sources it should have been deleted but
it wasn't and eventually this
information was printed in books and
told University lectures until after 10
years somebody realized that the article
was just created by probably an
Australian teenager named Jared
Owens so Wikipedia is not
perfect but Studies have shown that it
contains fewer factual inaccuracies than
encyclopedia britanica and I think
that's really impressive
when I was in
the in the summer of 2020 I kept posting
my favorite
trivia like physically I was quarantined
but I was exploring the world things
like breast shaped Hills or this unusual
chess
opening I definitely was aware that
there were islands and lakes like I knew
that was a thing but it had never
occurred to me that there could be an
island in a lake on an island I also had
never thought about the possibility of
an island in a Lake on an island in a
lake and I had definitely never
considered the idea of an island in a
lake on an island in a lake on an
island Wikipedia is just huge it has 6.6
million articles in English
alone but it's not done Wikipedia needs
editors like you to contribute to free
knowledge whether that's small things
like fixing commas or adding sources or
big things like heavy content editing or
making sure people aren't using it for
advertisements um there are some fun
ways to contribute this is a website
called wik Shoot me. tool
forge.com contributors are about 80%
male so there are a lot of efforts with
editons and marketing campaigns to get
more people
editing um I'll remind you it's created
by very normal real people this couple
in 2008 noticed that there were no
photos on the Wikipedia article for fi
for high five so they took matters in
their own hands acting out the sequence
up high down low victim misses and two
slow with finger guns and then they
added a hyperlink so you can go visit
the finger gun article if you want
to I thought this was very Charming when
I first saw it and so I reached out to
them I track them down it turns out
after this after they did this they
started dating they got married they had
kids and they agreed to recreate the
photos with their
[Applause]
kids so I
um
people take the task of writing an
encyclopedia very
seriously I said that I get really into
trivia some of these people will spend a
long time doing very trivial things
there was a long debate on whether the
caption guy standing sitting was too
funny for an
encyclopedia they eventually removed the
caption there was a 40,000 word
discussion on whether to capitalize the
eye in Star Trek Into
Darkness there was an even longer
discussion on whether this thing should
be called corn or maze maze is winning
as an arbor will be happy to
know so ultimately like I kind of laugh
at this sort of meticulous detail but
I'm glad that people are thinking this
deeply about things especially in an era
of social media filter Bubbles and
24-hour news Cycles when truth looks
different depending depending on where
you look people on Wikipedia are coming
together to write history in real
time I think the inner workings of an
online encyclopedia are
fascinating turns out other people do
too when I was a student here last year
I started Moonlighting as a journalist
explaining how a site this big gets made
by volunteers I wrote about how when
after Russia invaded Ukraine downloads
of Wikipedia skyrocketed in Russia as
the state was limiting Free Press
Wikipedia is not perfect but clearly
it's an information source that people
desire or when the queen died I wrote
about the Wikipedia editor that was so
quick to change her article into past
tense I kept posting online and I was
getting a following and I started
leading editons to get more people to
contribute then I started doing comedy
shows and I was surprised to learn that
one I thought it was fun but also people
were excited to pay money to go to a
show about an
encyclopedia I'm still really drawn to
useless knowledge like Diego the
tortoise who had so much sex that he
saved his
species let some Applause for him great
I'll let him
know or I like boops boops in a bucket I
just like
that but I really wouldn't call it youth
useless knowledge I don't think I would
call anything useless knowledge because
the thing about trivia is that it's an
invitation to learn more about a subject
you might learn a trivia fact and
suddenly you're far more interested and
you're learning about things you never
thought were interesting before Ken
Jennings once said trivia was the bait
on the fish hook of
Education I previously had little
interest in the Romantic Period of piano
music and then I learned that fron list
he had such good looks and like dramatic
performances that these like girls in
the 1800s in Europe were getting
diagnosed with something called list
fever because they were such fan girls
suddenly I'm interested in piano music
history similarly I didn't have a lot of
interest in life in the 13th century and
then I learned about this boy named
anfim and he was a six-year-old and his
random birch bark drawings birch bark
drawings were preserved and he wrote
things that you would see a six-year-old
draw today like these proclamations like
I am a wild beast and his little his
stick figure drawings with too many
fingers they look like something that a
six-year-old would draw
today it reminded me that for all of
history people have always been
people sometimes with trivia you start
somewhere random and then you start
thinking about empathy and geopolitics
and who knows science what have you
facts are really powerful even fun facts
and luckily we live in a time where
information has never been easier to
access whether you're looking for
fictional worms or nonwater floods or
more serious things like um atmospheric
carbon
data if nothing else trivia reminds you
that the world is huge and it's amazing
and it's really interesting and I don't
think that's trivial at all